all right we're looking hello Verena
blazing chest as you know I am Emily
Trask I work at the Chess Club these are
my ladies that technically on assure of
its teaches for ladies night none of my
ladies for intermediator here but we're
gonna take them through and I hope we
have fun all right
are you ladies ready okay so I'm going
to play this first game so there's four
challenges but I'm going to pick this
one because it's unlimited time I like
in limited time and he has a
questionable 1,500 rating and I I feel
comfortable with that so I'm gonna
accept it all right he is white to play
first so I'm gonna wait for him to move
and then we'll get started
she's not moving I guess we'll just wait
crazy k 11 I don't know if you're on the
stream but haha okay all right be five
yeah essentially my idea all right
defend that guy background oh go with
that that's fine
yeah please by all means yell out
whatever you think I should do meet 3b3
yeah I mean born before just take it
ah sure we'll run away
I took a free pond there trying to be
quiet he's taking his time
but that's okay it's unlimited time
yours lady because I'm late cuz it's a
castle yeah baby
that's why nice we're not prepared for
this
yeah yeah that's basically what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna quite I'm basically
go after oh and thank you change made
into elite crazy someone has been on
stock fish lately we're just he's taking
it lifetime control do accept as a
challenge I'll play 10 minutes if I'm
feeling really good I'll play 5 minutes
I don't care about increment or delay
technically my guys don't want me to
play ultimate it's not a big deal if we
do unlimited sorry but yeah 95 minutes
do you ladies have a preference on what
you want to put timewise
I would play unlimited let's see what
happens I understand 10 minutes is the
fastest maybe he's taking his time
hey crazy yeah after a while I'm
probably gonna have to go on to the next
game 10 11
Wow okay so my guys are telling me that
we shouldn't play on limited time
control you should try and do a time
control of some separate 15 minutes okay
15 minutes ten minutes five minutes ruk
Oh
he pinned me I'm not worried about it
well what's nice is that when I first
was on the stream I just had actually
helping me and she's a little less on my
level so she could really help we have
like all you ladies it'll be even if we
have a lot of time control would be a
lot easier
Oh see do you ladies have any
suggestions I think moved upon ya vb3
hmm oh no this is b3 so you mean b6
let's see anyone else saying any
question or not going to accept three
plus two sorry
not there yet you just need more
practice
oh yeah but I won't be scared about it
let's go here I'm sorry I would say by
all means
Oh Center seven minutes is that okay is
there an option
[Laughter]
Darren athlete lastly I hope I said that
right
um asks what got each of us into chess I
don't know who wants to go first I will
me my father taught me
so from there I developed interest and I
was like keep talking about chess all
the time so I I thought it was time to
learn
is a membership here and I always wanted
to learn chess so I decided for new
year's resolution my father taught me
when I was like seven and of course I
didn't remember anything and then like
three months before I started working at
the club a really good friend of mine
taught me how to play and I just wanted
to be six minutes like that but it was
really nice because after I started
working at the club I was like oh at
least now I know the basics I can start
playing now and it only took me a little
less than a year to kind of get to my
level so oh well just take it
please have any suggestion
any ideas maybe you can you can attack
the cream drink
rook mm-hmm
take the other night yeah to protect
them
how would I take this night no no oh
this little yeah yeah we can take it
back drunk of know this okay this can be
taken
yes I see what you're saying honest
talking about our music none of us have
chest titles except I wanna share a
[ __ ] who's not of course we don't have
any masters helping us
[Music]
you would take it you want me to take it
with my night of my work crazy is going
crazy
I think next we need to take out the
Queen
[Laughter]
I think we should go here predicting the
this guy predicting the night and do is
great that do you have any other
suggestions and you'll be out of the pin
answer
he's okay with that idea anything else I
think that's the best idea right now
because then Laurel goes here and then
you can also move your pawn to take the
king should be easy trying to do yeah uh
Donna Patrick Daly wants us to tell you
tell Anna you played black in the Evans
gambit that's all I said that's all I
said for women against one man
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah
Queen overhead Queen to c5 uh-huh
do any of you wish to have chest titles
yeah yeah it's a lot of I want to keep
it as a hobby I think it's time
consuming education for to get it
chest title so I don't think I'm sorry
yeah me it's a lot of work
I would like to forget the chance
developed right first pursuing other
things so the next game that we play we
should so now we have 13 challenges hmm
so this guy's 2300 this one is so this
guy his rating is a little lower and it
is a a faster game but because his
rating is lower and we have several of
us ladies it'll be a lot easier
oh this one 10 for 15 we can do that and
then there's see there's plenty more we
can just keep going a 1,500 rated oh I
need excuse me I'm okay I'm okay I'll
get it later okay
you should have water they're talking
there's much
I'm not scrolled all the way up see
only three days move challenges I lost
that's how I play would you know did the
spongebob okay so we just take this
someone says me just the phone against
you for Queen this candle is not lit
right now I don't that's a very
important question I understand yes I
understand
well someone is from mean I guess we can
ask the audience where they're all from
anyone from st. Louis
anyone in Missouri
just sit here yes oh yes
this is a good game
oh here comes my comer he's very popular
Oh someone's me Jamaica that's cool so
sorry are you gonna play next mmm okay
cool and then do we want to do like an
order of who goes next door we're gonna
okay India Italy are urgent to Nancy now
my list Germany England what part of
Germany Florida
what part of Germany's Florida another
one from Brazil oh wow okay mmm say BK
to CNN to the Germans
funny we had to do hi drew drew is one
of our associates and he's watching this
dream
Jonathan will do the same thing he'll
watch our stream and he's one of her
associates Oh
Jonathan's like 1,800 I think you can
give a check great I'm sorry I feel like
I'm just moving and stuff I'm not asking
you ladies if you have any ideas
all these they liked my idea uh no no
that's a vintage and make it right no no
none of us have been innovators Oh Miles
Davis his roots are in st. Louis that's
cool no one else from st. Louis know
anyone from Turkey Oh see Jonathan
chances in the queue will see Jonathan I
played him on my first stream and he's
at home right now and he has three kids
and he had to change a diaper halfway
through and so I I don't remember I
think I did
or it was checkmate I don't remember the
fact that I was what did you plead that
I was planning to get the root code oh
yeah we could still do that
oh no not coming after hurricane coming
after everything actually a place that
will care attacking the Queen look at a
queen sure why not Anna saying it's a
head sleep he'll take it I mean he can
he can take it
we're gonna wait wait I don't think it's
a little as you can tell on here this
dreams a delayed yeah
but eventually you'll hear if he doesn't
move see everyone's like no no you lazy
okay you can take it yeah who are the
ladies they want to know who we are you
know who I am
[Laughter]
there are there are students for our one
and only ladies night class best class
yeah
why isn't he moving this is why this is
why they don't want to sell you
unlimited because also the audience is
like now we want to
but do you ladies kind of understand
like how the dynamic works of like these
are the challenges all that information
this is how we play won't give you that
well I guess I can't take that bishop I
mean here did you
yeah but we're probably gonna have to
end our game soon because he's taking
spoiler ha ha coin at six
see he even said he's waiting for the
stream to catch up to read your minds so
but it's not that intimidating right you
ladies can play yeah yeah yeah which is
why we recommend at least the club kind
of recommends
he's making some space for his game yeah
like we recommend to like play because
then you'll play in person more often
and before you I do a live stream did
you have a different idea
all right you blended a queen no no no
I'm sorry
it's unanimous Michelle do you want to
take her seat
yeah the audience thinks they should
resign I do that all the time just
casually I'm leaping left the right
right I mean we can go for a chick we're
just gonna wait so I wait for a little
bit and then you can please you have to
be on chest comm right reaches to play
us
there he made a move ha oh I didn't even
get the chance to choose and then
all right fine you take off your
microphone put it right here okay so you
don't want to play Unlimited is too cool
you don't want to do casual you want to
do rated yeah sorry do you leave also
want to look and maybe say oh you should
play this one you should play that one
who had a highest rating of you on
well other than do any of you ladies
actually have like a USDA breeding or
any kind of reading at all yeah you have
what do you your ratings on just I come
yeah I guess that would probably make me
the highest rated but not by that much I
think I like this guy my string of
strange addiction' short long it's rated
it's 10 minute game short go ahead
[Laughter]
Phoenicia which one well a lot of people
will go on the comments though so this
one
Akash 9i 933 wants to play dark panda
wants to play as Opie wants to play my
boss Jonathan France wants to play this
guy's username is um whatever okay let's
do 15 minutes and that is a casual game
so we don't want to do casual this one
I'm sorry guys we want to play rated
games so yeah they're just fun yeah yeah
1500 yeah go ahead
all right so we're black again no words
gonna wait and okay I believe in you saw
dia
Oh Jonathan trance I'm sorry I'll owe
you a game when we work next that makes
you feel better I'm gonna lose but if
you guys have any questions about the
club or about ladies night just comment
i'll answer them it it's random believe
me I'd love to play white I know I also
thought that was kind of weird yeah I
guess I don't have any anything good for
you
yes thank you good
can I get another shout out my mom is
watching my mom has probably asleep to
be going back to the game
Hey mmm the awkwardness is just so
intense right now people are in the club
as ladies that's kind of a hard question
Shay could probably answer how many
ladies come to ladies night a little
better because the club members are we
have a lot so I mean I couldn't tell you
how many are actually ladies
no how many ladies do you think come to
your Lee's nine on average your specific
quest six on average something like that
okay I usually have four to five ladies
yeah something like that 20 ladies
something like that on a good day right
right right of course right none of the
ladies come on the winter
that's right that's right and we have a
girls like girls under 13 14 girls only
camp for like the week so that's also
really nice now the guys are also the
the not the guys the streamer is the
streamers are kind of giving you they'll
say so this one says stick Oh someone
says b6 someone says at five nishan I am
Emily trash yeah yeah yeah
someone else says at five oh no I'm the
same person I'm sorry yeah thank you
someone says c5 no it's not men only
groups it just so happens that men are
the only ones that show up to our other
classes and we're hoping to get more
ladies involved in other classes that's
course of course of course yeah it was
only after of course of course so we
don't have to
[Laughter]
this is a tricky position okay I think
that's good yeah yeah I know what do you
think of your ladies doing so far are we
doing good there's a lady that wants to
play us Oh Lady voices lady yeah your
your user name is Juliana that would be
[Music]
[Laughter]
right right hopefully we'll get Y next
time I'm sorry you were preparing white
do you think that every Thursday at 8:30
is good or do you should another day be
better maybe well we won't be able to do
it right after and it ends at 7:30 but
they have we're live-streaming our other
class which starts at 7:30 and we have
to wait for that to end which I also
thought about yes
we can absolutely do that Danny did you
say nope well I'll talk to the guys and
see what we can do and then I'll come to
you with the options and we'll figure
out something
[Music]
yeah absolutely yeah and then if you
please you get a chance you can go out
to dinner again and hopefully I'll be
able to actually go one night we'll see
well the other thing is I used to just
work 12 to 8 on Thursdays and now I'm
working 2 to 10 so if I was to go and be
during my shift so it just depends we'll
have to see
of course yes yes yes I would love to
you I and plus I'm kind of in charge in
the schedule well how are you doing
Sonia someone says Queen d7 yeah we
played that oh good good good let's see
I think silence a long dream girl rating
what rating is a woman playing Emily
Towson sorry is like a woman playing
rating ladies her thousand it's true
and I'm gonna help what happened to the
viewers choice class that was supposed
to show you today yeah that is a good
question Patrick we had an event going
on that was taking up that space where
that class was supposed to be and
basically we didn't have a space where
it could have gone so we had to cancel
it for today but it will be back next
week I promise he wanted to know why one
of our classes was canceled because they
was supposed to stream tonight and it
wasn't just swindle him oh we're up on
time nice Nikki do you wanna do you
wanna play next
oh yeah we're gonna play that on that um
oh my girl Giuliana
thank you yes we'll have to play
Giuliana checkmated in this game we're
waiting we're going to checkmate
someone says yeah oh no don't put
pressure on me people keep sayin a six
it sounds like that's the way of their
room let's just play
but you ladies are interested in doing
this the following weeks correct I mean
if this dream likes us you might be
turned oh we got checkmated okay so you
need take off your mic you need to take
off yours sleeves walk around you don't
have a mic on see you're okay go ahead
sit there go ahead and put that mic on
does anyone want to take Michelle spoon
[Laughter]
yep perfect my microphone fell laughs
like it always does go ahead click that
we're gonna look for Julie on it Oh
perfect she's right there ray didn't
blink
you don't have to but you can just call
me for block this thing all right good
luck Nikki I like I'm if that's gonna be
nice like this we haven't today in trash
talking I I keep taking a five oh I'm
sorry
Eva no no yes we don't have to but that
is my suggestion but then we'll take I
mean you lose it yeah yeah I know we can
support the bond yeah
that is quite a username Flavius Daniel
mind SI entertainment right in your way
Saudi oh I'm sorry
no well I don't know if you can tell but
literally right now I wouldn't say to
move your palm just because it opens
your yeah key defense but that's just my
opinion to detects the I don't think
that banana is issue because it's a pin
to Queen
don't keep your pinion pin right but if
he takes we can just always to yeah we
could do Bishop to Bishop to you
thank you someone says h3 Thank You
Danny I can't hear you okay h3 but like
you know you need to keep the key
mission to e you ship to you - you got
Danny's approval of that you like 700
yeah I just taken just a it
Thanks oh you could have also taken it
with you tonight but it I don't what
ever heard of the matter uh nishan what
do you mean why only girls I don't know
you mean you don't like us oh I see what
you're saying
no we will gladly plate you guys it's
just it's the first time the ladies have
been on the stream so I think that's why
but it's not women only I'm gonna need
some news night
[Music]
yeah yeah I like it yeah but like if you
take this is to expose that c3 pawn to
c3 that one yeah c3 why not
no c3 popular vote um I want to see an
anti chest strain on to d4 thanks Danny
our stream keeps saying h3 we could play
Age 3 okay let's see what happens here
Oh someone's helping us
oh all right G are our H files open with
our Brooke so it's kind of scary yeah
[Laughter]
this is a good this is a good stream C
3G 3G three I'm sorry I think no I think
this is still
uhh Flavius Daniel - I entertainment go
ahead with your questions I have to say
that username it's just take it take it
with your pawn take that pawn with your
Yvonne my rating is like kind of twelve
hundred maybe thirteen on a good day
[Laughter]
push which oh he'll on passant if we go
there are cf3 after you're right you're
right
because yeah yeah sorry
like three three okay okay you're sure
there's something here and then we could
also move our Bishop because it's been
in that corner for a while yeah there's
so much going on here
anna is like trying to help us without
really helping pay more attention to the
kingside yeah puzzle a puzzle rush yes
no no no with the night with the night
oh no I know
the king on the other side yeah
I don't see why not yeah I think because
I really wanna help well if you want on
a we can find the the actual notation
and so next week you could go over the
cave I get that he's attacking our
communion and it'll be made if we don't
do something about it
no that's Mickey you can play another
game so do you you can play another game
what do you ladies want to do oh thank
you so we have time for maybe one more
game you ladies can absolutely stay but
I'll need to go so I understand if you
ladies are not comfortable with me not
being here
so who wants to play next you have your
microphone off oh yeah yeah yeah because
my first stream didn't go so well
there you go you can have that one so
just get to play we have a few requests
Mogi moo moo i can't pronounce
like 1500 whoever is hosting for 10
minutes I'll let you decide I'll just be
here that's consolation I've lost more
games in my life than all three have
been all three of us have played and
combined go ahead and just did you
already click that's good go ahead and
put that yeah and then it should perfect
we got blink again I feel like this was
a good first stream I would develop your
night yeah
oh the my god so if you go to YouTube on
your phone and you can just search st.
Louis chess club and it should it'll
have my face
on the front you can just like copy that
link
oh you look like you're having such a
hard time yeah yeah well it's also like
this is my second stream I feel much
more comfortable by my first dream I was
just like drunk
they didn't great it's our first time
let us ease into it yeah but it's you're
cracking me up right right right let's
see um why not ace it we already wait a
minute
yeah I would run away oh they took us an
hour but we're good we have time do you
say we died we have time we have time oh
okay we take it with our yes ticket free
and free Bishop you sure I can't help
you because nobody would have played
against you though yeah I get that I get
that we are too excited to see then
yeah where we're going there
yeah screen c4 yeah
oh yeah I say we should cancel key yeah
and yeah we'll have to get our Bishop
yeah we could probably put our knight on
g6 nothing Knight takes fun cuz yeah
because then the exchange is good you
know before I answer your question you
shine I want to ask why you want to know
how old I am
[Laughter]
we should we want to do I think we
should use that's me
we could either take the night with our
night we could take the bishop with our
bishop we could Castle queenside
just whatever you want I mean we
probably could queenside castle you're
probably right how do you ladies feel
right now they're in the zone I love it
our queen is attacked our queen is
attacked our queen is attacked we could
take the night with our queen cuz then
if they didn't exchange with our
logistics to entertainment think we
should have by like the audience those
hard poles devices you you be on this
stream next week oh they do want a queen
yeah
yeah no pressure but 93 92 93
[Music]
yeah everyone liked our taking the I can
find out so we have 56 people watching
right now nice cozy community what are
they saying
yeah so we can't take the pawn should we
do something should oh they want to stay
okay sure yeah I love it
okay take the take the ball take the
phone do you tune queen Jake's takes G -
where does G -
oh I knew that I'm like be too nice
alright so the club closes at 10:00 we
only have 20 minutes we probably don't
have time to play another game don't
don't leave just yet dealies want to
look on the stream just for a second and
say hey goodbye thank you no you don't
have to do it you can okay um we don't
know when we will be back next but we
obviously want to be we want to be back
right okay we obviously do want to be
back I have to talk with the video
Department guys and my boss and then
we'll figure out a day and then we'll
see you guys next week all right that's
it